l'après fort j'avais dit que
les finitions complémentaires puisque il
ya toute une panoplie
chacune a des possibilités et c'est moi
qu'on travaille qu'on qu'on a fait on
envoie un petit peu davantage que ça
apporte indéniablement
puisqu'aujourd'hui les filles sont
capables de rouler vite ensemble et
c'est ça tout l'intérêt de ce travail
auquel est aussi le palmarès de cette
élection lamartine est belle le palmarès
de cette sélection la martinique au tour
de guadeloupe si voici une épreuve on
n'a pas ôté en 2015 en 2016
on fait
deuxième il a aidé année en 2017 ont
fait 2e et 3e c'est vous dire est
deuxième avec christine batardeau est
3ème avec mélissa alexandrine s'il ne
prouve que
on a toujours vous montrer que la
sélection de martinique
à une bonne image quoi alors
qu'attendez-vous de 2018
mais qu'est ce qu'on attend de 2018
c'est déjà de reconquérir le titre
puisque ça fait deux ans que ça nous
échappe
lundi dernier on a une concurrente de
valeur qui inquiets de voir supérieures
par rapport à nous on a quand même mis
le maillot on a fait ce qu'il fallait
mais cette année avec l'équipe que nous
avons un poste bien figurer déjà et
conquérir à nouveau se disent plutôt pas
mal
on a tout
on a plus assez progressé dans l'esprit
de cohésion et tout
au niveau physique aussi ça va bien pour
tout le monde donc ça devrait aller pour
le déplacement
quel est l'objectif pour 2018 emporté
lotis oui bien sûr c'est l'objectif
d'essayer d'aller prendre le titre
on est surtout un esprit de cohésion et
puis sur les derniers entraînements on a
pu vraiment exploiter
cela en fait
sera rouler avec une très bonne cadeaux
ce
toujours en étant sur les scouts
cohésion